Bill, this is a big day for Microsoft with Windows 10.
Are you finding yourself checking your phone?
How does it feel when you see your former company go through a day like today...
...and a bit of a resurgence over there in many ways?
Yeah, Satya Nadella, the new CEO has been in charge about a year now.
It's exciting.
He's taking the company, having an embrace and lead on some new areas...
...that's got some influence on the new products that are coming out there.
He's had me come in and consult with some of the groups.
So it's exciting.
I think it's not just a one day thing and the months ahead...
...as we see how developers react...
...as we get out later this year on the product they're shipping.
Windows is core and so the breakthrough things they've done there,...
...I'm excited to see the reaction.